salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique comme vous pouvez le
voir le décor de la chaîne a légèrement
changé par rapport à ce qu'il était
avant
c'est normal avant cette chaîne
s'adressait à tous avec une grille de
lecture de droite notamment sur les
sujets culturels et j'ai décidé de la
transformer en chêne d'extrême gauche
progressiste alors pourquoi ça et bien
parce qu'il ya quelques temps j'ai
rencontré des militants progressistes
qui m'ont dit christophe tu as un mâle
blanc si ce genre et théo patriarcal
turbo diesel et c'est oppressif et le
fait qu'on le dise m'a permis de prendre
conscience qu effectivement j'étais un
mâle blanc si ce genre hétéro
patriarcale turbo diesel et que j'étais
oppressif et du coup je me suis dit mais
moi je vais dans le camp du bien je ne
veux pas oppressif
je veux être opprimé et du coup depuis
je suis gender fluide c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je suis un homme
mais demain je serai peut-être une femme
ou un kangourou également j'ai décidé de
rejoindre un petit groupe militant lgbt
plus qui s'appelle génération identité
de genre fluide et non binaire qui fait
la promotion
dès l'écriture inclusive des théories du
genre et de la déconstruction du système
et héros patriarcale auprès des élèves
de maternelle et de primaire élèves qui
sont extrêmement emballé par ses idées
également nous militons pour la remise
ration parce que nous estimons qu'on a
déjà cédé français à qu'il faut
expliquer l'écriture inclusive et la non
binarité d'or cent en plus voire à
l'expliquer aux étrangers mais attention
on est de gauche
donc on est pour une rémunération de
gauche c'est-à-dire solidaire équitable
et bio dégradable de toute façon leur
migration à la base c'est un concept
écologistes puisqu'il s'agit ni plus ni
moins que le tri sélectif les maliens
dans le charter les algériens dans le
bateau bref en tout cas maintenant sur
cette chaîne
eh bien nous allons dénoncer car comme
le dit le slogan de gauche dénonce et
c'est exister un slogan qu'il ne faut
pas forcément prendre au pied de la
lettre puisque dans certaines périodes
notamment par exemple en cas
d'occupation nazie dénoncé c'est sympa
ça permet d'avoir des réductions
d'impôts et de récupérer des meubles
gratis mais en période de libération ça
peut créer quelques soucis donc slogans
comme toujours à adapter au contexte
historique en tout cas sur cette chaîne
donc maintenant nous allons dénoncer
tout ce qui est oppressif et nous allons
commencer à s'attaquer à un monument de
l'oppression
culturel un dessin animé qui sous
couvert et bien d'amusement populaire de
divertissement fait en fait la promotion
d'idées et de théories totalement
nauséabonde
j'ai nommé le roi lion allez c'est parti
d'abord les lions véhicules tous les
clichés du système et héros patriarcal
loin de la réalité de ces animaux que ça
soit mufasa et sa femme ou nahla et
simba on a une apologie du couple et de
la famille qui correspondent aux schémas
et valeurs bourgeoises occidental un
papa une maman un mâle et une femelle
et puis c'est un film insidieusement
raciste qui banalise le suprématisme
blanc notamment par le jeu des couleurs
les lions qui sont du bon côté ont un
pelage clair alors que ce quart lui un
pelage très foncée trop foncée pour être
réelle scarlett un décalque de jafar
dans aladdin dans la position de
subalternes et la volonté de conquête du
pouvoir mais aussi jusque dans la
palette graphique utilisé il représente
tout comme jafar de façon moins subtile
l'archétype du moyen-orientale perfide
cruel et assoiffé de pouvoir
sous couvert de lutte interne à un clan
en fait on évoque une guerre des races
ou les blancs sont les gentils c'est un
film qui est raciste aussi dans sa
conception technique dans son casting
rafiki un babouin un singe est doublé
par robert guillaume un afro américain
le message est limpide le noir est un
saint jean c'est du racisme classique
rafik est aussi symboliquement l'esclave
qui est content de servir le [ __ ] de
maison comme disait malcom x
on a aussi le personnage de shenzi dont
le sous texte politique est abominable
c'est une hyène c'est la cheffe du
groupe puisque lé guen ont une société
matriarcale
et elle est là subalternes du grand
méchant donc déjà on est critique anti
féministe la femme ne peut être le chef
que dans une société de charognards et
en étant l'esclave d'un mal qui est dans
le mauvais camp
de plus elle est doublée en version
originale par whoopi goldberg une femme
noire
on nous sous-entend donc que la femme
noire qui plus est quand elle a du
pouvoir
quand elle se rebelle contre le mâle
blanc et dans le mauvais camp il faut
aussi ajouter que ses acolytes sont deux
idiots on a donc aussi un discours
psycho fob et qui décrit les alliés
d'une femme noire comme étant des
imbéciles c'est une véritable critique
du progressisme il y a également
l'apologie du capitalisme et de la
domination sociale
il ya une échelle hiérarchique où le
prédateur domine et où les faibles sont
heureux d'être dominé par l'effort vous
avez tous les herbivores qui sont
heureux d'être du gibier ils prêtent
même hommage à leurs bourreaux
vous avez aussi une séquence où les
herbivores chante avec simba alors que
la première chose qu'ils demandent à
timon et pumbaa quand ils rencontrent
ces cellules n'ont pas de l'hippopotame
à manger
[Musique]
non mais les mecs qui veut vous bouffez
réagissent et arrêter de chanter avec
lui défoncer lui sa gueule au roi lion
non mais c'est vrai les herbivores dans
ce dessin animé sont encore plus
serviles que des syndicalistes cfdt
ça m'énerve bref continuons et puis il
ya les personnages de timon et pumbaa
deux personnages hautement problématique
au début il représente une sorte
d'utopie progressiste où le travail est
abolie hakuna matata c'est un peu une
synthèse de tous les slogans des
radicales sixties interdit d'interdire à
jouir sans entraves etc
mais très vite quand il rencontre simba
les choses changent pour le mâle blanc
hétéro patriarcale représenté par simba
qui se laissent séduire au début par ce
mode de vie il s'avère que c'est une
impasse pour lui et il finit par partir
prendre le pouvoir chez lui et nos deux
acolytes à ce moment là vont se ranger
derrière lui et l'aider dans sa quête du
pouvoir au lieu de rester dans leur
étable nature paisible
on a deux personnages qui sont censés
incarner le progressisme qui au contact
du pouvoir vont se transformer en droit
tard ils deviennent néoconservateurs
d'ailleurs au fond si leur mode de vie
initiale et libertaire le même
représentent des archétypes de la droite
la plus réactionnaire pumba est sale
crade
il représente le redneck les lecteurs de
trump avant l'heure quant à timon son
nom fait immanquablement penser à simon
un nom juif qui représente le sionisme
allié traditionnel de la droite
américaine
on a donc deux sidekick du héros qui
sont rendu sympathique alors que
politiquement ils sont totalement
réactionnaire
bref ce dessin animé et posent
énormément problème et devrait au
minimum être interdits aux moins de 18
ans et qui portait un hangar avant le
début en tout cas si cette vidéo vous a
intéressé
et vous a convaincu et bien n'hésitez
pas à les voir la définition du second
degré sur internet ou dans un
dictionnaire et si elle vous a fait
sourire et bien n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait et sur ce
jeudi à la prochaine